you get that moment where sophia and and
i are both on camera
and it's just that that heartwarming
feeling like teary eyed like you know
we're back to see zachary zachary levi
jack and you know we also have some new
additions to the cast some new people
so um it feels so good you know to to be
back in
billy batson and you know it's it's
going to be so much fun
i think now that i've felt those certain
feelings and and have
experienced love and all and you know
this and that as a teenager you know
it's it's
you really get to put that into
songwriting and you know make it
you know your own and really tell a
story
ask your angel so good to chat with you
congratulations on
everything you've got going on including
your guest star role on high school
musical
the musical this year let's go the trick
is to cry if you're
trying to talk a gate agent excuse me
the french girl routine earlier it was
ultimately a failure but it was
entertaining nonetheless
how excited are you i'm so excited i
can't wait for the fans to see this
episode
it's really special you know it's a
reunion episode with sophia and i
so there's a lot of things we need to
cover i can't wait i'm ecstatic can't
wait
well you mentioned the mini reunion that
you're having
let's start with that i mean how great
was it to
finally reunite with her it's so great i
mean when i walked onto set
you know it just the atmosphere it's so
lively and
you know the cast is obviously so
talented and it's such a special show
and
getting to see sophia i think the last
time i saw her was
a long time ago so you know she's a
she's a woman it's so weird
and she's older and and she's she's so
talented and
it's like nothing changed like it's like
we're picking up right where we left off
and uh as soon as they called action the
chemistry was there everything was there
and it's like we were back so it's it's
insane we had so much fun
back but just a different project a
little bit with a different project
was that almost challenging for you at
all was there a moment when you were
with sophia where you had to remind
yourself okay this is not andy mackey
right right right
no totally 100 like i think i think it
was the first scene like i think i
almost gave off like a jonah type of
like energy and vibe and i was like whoa
wrong show buddy so no definitely yeah
there was definitely
a moment where um i was we were in that
world what
drew you to the character to jack i
think what i really like about him is he
puts other people before himself
which is kind of great and it's a great
quality to have he's just a nice human
you know he's he's a good guy he's
charming he sees this girl over there
and
you know the first thing that he thinks
of is you know she seems down let me let
me go lift up
her spirits and you know that's what he
goes and he goes and does that and
kind of see you know where that journey
takes these two you know
these two people so what can fans expect
with the episode that you're in i know
you obviously can't give away
too much how would you describe it i
think i would just have to say
the uh gosh i don't even know there's so
many things
i know i think just um that you get that
moment where
sophia and and i are both on camera and
it's just that that heartwarming
feeling like teary eyed like you know
we're back you know it's obviously
you know high school musical but it it's
it feels like you know wherever i go and
wherever she goes it's like we always
are able to find each other whether it's
a different character and just be back
at home and
you know write with each other so i
don't i don't know exactly how to
explain this feeling but um it's just
that's the best i can put into words i
guess
it's a family feel it's a family it
really is it's a family feeling
and going off of that obviously the high
school musical
family is such a fun
talented group of young actors i mean
how much fun did you have on set with
everybody
everyone was so welcoming unfortunately
i didn't get to be with everyone
ugh but i was with everyone on zoom and
you know when i got there
into utah it's the same crew so you know
it felt like a welcome roll
yeah we shot in utah we shot the first
one yeah the andy mack in utah so it was
it was literally a reunion when i say a
reunion everything literally everywhere
similar literally everywhere and you
know i did get to spend time with matt
cornett and
such a nice talented guy and him and
sophia and i were having so much fun
together and
oh it's just a dream come true that's
all i can say really well speaking of
dreams coming true kid you
are just booked and busy every time
like i hear your name you're always up
to something amazing and
the last time you and i spoke you had
mentioned that
filming for the shazam sequel would be
soon have you guys filmed yet
we haven't no i'm just kidding i had to
say no we're shooting right now i'm in
atlanta
we're shooting this second one um i've
been here since
may so yeah we're shooting everything's
going great so
it's crazy because it's so long overdue
you know so to be back it feels so good
how great has it been to reunite with
your shazam family
it's so great you know to see zachary
levi jack and you know we also have
some new additions to the cast some new
people so um it feels so good
you know to to be back in billy batson
and you know it's
it's gonna be so much fun i think this
sequel is gonna it's definitely gonna
follow up the first movie
are you happy with the script i'm so
happy with the script
it's so good it's so good there's so
many things it's kind of got everything
you want in a superhero movie it's
it's got those heartfelt moments the
action the comedy and it's just
everything you've ever wanted
to tell i guess to see um on on the big
screen so i'm excited you are busy
filming right now but do you have any
other big plans for the summer
to release music i think yes that's
number one on my list right now so i'm
getting ready to hopefully put some
stuff out there um because you know
quarantine and
coed and that'll happen so kind of
stopped all that so the process is going
well and i'm i'm pumped can't wait
[Music]
with this new music is some of it
inspired by
the relationship that you're in now and
new love
yeah i think i think so yeah i mean when
you're writing songs about
things that you haven't felt it's kind
of hard to interpret
in in a way so i think now that i've
felt those certain feelings and
and have experienced love and all and
you know this and that as a teenager you
know it's it's
you really get to put that into
songwriting and you know make it
you know your own and really tell a
story so i like that i'm able to like
really
hone in on that now and and do that so
i'm happy oh he's so in love
look at your little face
you